oh that can't exclusive
let's pound 88.3 way up up lift you you
made the Angelo boo that cab wassup just
do right here Rob Dyrdek
kind of famous kind of famous um he's
got a short but it's also I feel real
safe in between they'll say to Arizona
version of oh you know what Rob Rob Rob
big yeah I like that I'm looking to kind
of try to pull that over his humble home
in unity yeah you just got you just got
a duck down put on some dc's man I'm
good to go I'd have to step up a little
bit since you have like shaking the
companies he gave me some pcs right yeah
we could we go I will lace you guys okay
for you Halloween outfits well speaking
of that man I know you're a pro skater
you got any tips for fat guys are trying
to go produce me big black do it didn't
work out very well minutes everything
anything you want to do you can do okay
okay and I mean that from the bottom of
my heart it takes a dedication right
heart soul and a whole lot of padding
okay I mean tons of panic because
aerodynamically my capable of another
step and you hit the ground a bit harder
you know so you can put out a hand or a
foot step snap you don't I mean you
don't want best you want to be nice and
padded and supportive
alright cool you can do anything I'm
going pro baby hey let's talk about man
I know you have a lot of roots here in
Phoenix you're you're always out here
you want me to start this event out here
in Phoenix timi Phoenix has always had
sort of a big position and sort of skate
culture on the west coast out sort of
outside of you know California and all
that and and you know for me not only
just you know the world's biggest skate
park manufacturer from here but the
place that I sort of did the initial
skate park skate plaza movement was a
company from here so bringing into here
and then we built a safe slot skate spot
last year we're building another one out
here and for me and this is a third time
here for Street League so and I just
enjoy Phoenix man I just really do about
unlike most people I actually like the
web people hate the heat man I just
there's nothing I do I hate to Miami
Heat you said it owes its really steamy
and humid
no I think he's talking about like
LeBron James he's lost the money I
about 16 bucks to this kid actually was
20 but I saw the bronze last weekend and
I said in Vegas yeah he hated on you
guys do how you feeling about that did
you burn a dirty - no no I was like to
me it's still like I want to be a
champion it doesn't matter it was you
know same stick but like I feel I like
seeing him win because I feel like it
was terrible over that whole year seeing
I'm just saying yeah it was depressing
you make me so nervous anyway what a bit
of a conflict with this tosh point-o
yeah what's up do we need to beat this
bull up yeah well what was the what was
the reason of the issue although the
issue is day for some he's convinced
that I have watched his show and then
copied it you know what I'm saying so
we're yeah I've said it a million
[__] times but I sold it to MTV
during Robin [__] you know at me so
right already in motion by the time it
came out but he got out of pocket then I
got a little out of pocket via Twitter
which you don't do because if you take
something personal you should probably
handle it yeah heard you say you're
gonna beat him up I didn't Rob that you
kind of didn't do it even says you gotta
said you and hear him set up a boxing
match he comes grab it out I'd certainly
never said there was any way yeah so you
know again hi he's got a resume be nice
to see him put again of what we like to
say is we're putting that behind us
we're putting in mine so if you guys
like run into each other it'll be all
all good it won't be like a 40-block the
game moment will you be good
that's a scary one day a man I was uh
I'm a little pissed off at you Rob why
I'm gonna tell you exactly why okay so
you were all and speaking to MTV you
were on Punk'd okay and you didn't let
the Biebs punky dude how you got to not
let the Biebs Punk you you could have
went through with it
I thought I was being robbed I didn't
think I was like they don't show you how
I was like I was like really on like
some
it's like that that was a hooker and
that was like a book this is like a
weird setup at first before I started
going out so and then when I when I when
he finally came walking out I felt I
felt so terrible because I felt like oh
I should just let it happen like I was
getting pwned even though like one of
the first things I said just a natural
reaction you're more or less saying this
is somebody [__] with me right now
like and I kept looking in dramas face
no more than MTV nah I trust him so much
that it was like what's going on right
now like blank and then when he was like
I have no idea I believe that he had no
idea like there's no way he's setting me
up you know but at the same time I would
much rather have another to talk about
not getting pumped by be everything
getting puffy that's true I mean who
gets [__] by Justin Bieber now rob
dyrdek hey she might be getting other
things done by her to make this will be
anyway what inspired you to start the
street league movement man because
there's only there's so many other skate
competitions of X Games there's you know
a lot of a lot of stuff that's out there
what inspired you to start a couple bugs
in there to Tk yeah but it's just the
reality of no one's ever done it right
you know I mean it's it's and it was for
me it's more about doing the proper
League for skateboarding and all the
professional skateboarders that are in
it so I what a pretty ominous task to
take on that whole world too since I did
it and you're completely myself but
again we partnered with ESPN and and
creating the true professional sports
entertainment property with pro
skateboarding is is what we set out to
do you know
there it is way man my mom was
ridiculousness how good I love it as
well my son loves a little little
cartoon so thanks for entertaining this
bro you know reshow
keep up the great work and if you need
tosh point-o to get his ass beat you're
the ones well i'm kind of look this
white
I start fights and I just someone's
asking y'all get along all right Joe
appreciate you man thank you very much
yes sir and don't forget like I'm gonna
get you guys your Halloween outfits
right yeah we're gonna hook you to that
and so big black the double B's I need
those who say we like we like free [__]
though all right so maybe I'll go pound
a 10.3 will they can't Rob Dyrdek we out
purse